[Musique]
mais protéger un tout petit peu macho
aujourd'hui bon et bien catherine
aujourd'hui je crois que vous êtes quoi
on savait que l'on faisant la grinta les
armes bon c'est bien cette dernière fois
je me suis ici c'est pour ça alors le
ont reçu des lettres vous en avez reçu
jamais reçu du monde dit mais de quoi
s'agit-il
est-ce que katherine étaient souffrants
que j'avais pris un siège
c'est ça alors voilà un bien passé un
petit morceau de vocalys que j'étais
souffrante outragé répondu qu'il n'était
rien qui en était rien je voulais
seulement me reposer puisque c'était la
cuisine pour les hommes voilà voilà un
tout petit morceau de vaud que je vais
escaloper quel morceau
il s'agit d'un morceau de noix de veau
en l'occurrence rémy pagani nom de la
recette écouter il s'agit d' alouettes
s'en est dit c'est très classique st
mais oui il y aura pas de variantes
si vous allez voir s'amuser
la 3d relief et ruitz bien filles aussi
fine que possible et quel morceau je
voulais déjà des quatre joueuses il a
dit que c'était benoît lecouls vous le
ferez plus est sûre c'est promis 2 400
goillot d'ailleurs j'avais perdu mon
compte 5 6 c'est à dire j'ai tellement
peur de me couper au vent et que je
faisais attention cette et victoire
alors ici qui me reste en petits
morceaux de veau sont en trop oui alors
je vais vous voyez vous le coupez comme
ceux ci en trois morceaux de façon à ce
qu'ils puissent passer dans la machine
je vais pas ici en morceaux de porc à
peu près la même quantité
le voilà le coup fait également en deux
seul essai de la chine c'est exact et du
jambon de bayonne jean non sec
j'aimerais coupé également et voilà
alors ceci vous pouvez en disposer
catenacci c'est très vrai alors voir les
choses que vous ne ferez jamais parce
que l'espère je pense que vous achèterez
les escalopes tout prêtre chez le
boucher que vous attend vous attend
cette augmentation fait du bruit
j'ai un peu d'eau je mouille la barre
attention à la wii
chaque fois obtenir des escalopes très
plate mais ça on peut faire à faire ça
très facilement pas son boucher sa vie
prévenu les ingénieurs du son il adore
ça les liens du sang et mon nez sans eau
l'hiver on s'ennuierait alors je vais
ranger ses escales open à côté de
l'autre comme ceux ci après impôts de
façon à pouvoir les assaisonner et puis
je m'en vais faire le suit tout de suite
tout de suite j'avais fait la farce
alors la farce la voie s'ils voulaient
voir l'envié de me passer ce petit
instrument
le joueur formé dans une assiette voilà
alors une recette qui compte pour le
concours de la cuisine pour les armes
je continue
voilà
[Musique]
tout seul
non
ça ne fait presque pas de
m
[Applaudissements]
aie aie alors non mélangeant une fois je
mets du coup il faut du port une fois du
jambon face à ce que déjà ce mélange
fait opérer quand je vais avoir terminé
ouais ça ça va être très vite fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes eux mêmes pour une fois je
n'ai pas si mal réussi
vous êtes en temps mais très content de
moi
oui
il n'y a pas que les gens étaient
contents d'eux
tous les égoïstes
ça c'était pas prévu par malema farce
voilà c'est terminé avouez que tout de
même ça a été rapide n'a pas ça vous a
pas donné beaucoup de mal je passe tout
ceci ici dans une petite série et je
vais ajouter un ou un enfant pied comme
ceux ci mais bien de déboires de quoi
aussi championne du monde et puis tant
que je tiens à la fois brillé à ces
zones est également resté alors du sel
alors du celte également ici et puis
également sur les estars des fines
herbes directement vous êtes bien actif
vous croirez arrive ici et là et puis ça
voyait encore liant notre plu piège bien
qu'il l'a assailli ça marche ça c'est un
tout petit peu d'épis également comme
ceci je vais à saupoudrer un petit peu
voient alors je mélange tout ceci ans en
ce sens ça y est j'ai toussé alors je
m'en vais partager cette farce
voyez-vous ici en huit parties égales
merci à vous quand vous aiguiller c'est
très efficace là alors hein
grand comme une oie peu près une bombe
est d'ailleurs rectifié au fur et à
mesure tout m faut pas encore dit non
voilà je vais partir des oeufs sans
tarder jusqu'à leur d'autruche y compris
non voilées tout cela voilà merci galli
alors ici je m'en vais rouler les
paupiettes les petites l'alouette
centaine sur elle même et puis quand
elles sont rouler avec tenez je voudrais
que vous enleviez fait ça pour moi on se
crée entre là ce sont des petites
caisses que c'est en réalité est qu'ils
sont de petites baguettes de bois pour
avec une petite pointe et ça ça va
servir donc accrocher ce soir c'est pour
remplacer des petites le fil on pouvait
mettre du film bien sûr et vous aviez
déjà expliqué que quand les enfants en
vacances s'ennuie un peu leur fait
préparer sans bon eh bien moi je finis
je voulais dans le paquet non je préfère
que vous l'avez pas saoul et oui en tout
cas 8
il me suffiront jamais très neuf au cas
où votre maladresse aux emprunts cassez
ne cesse alors on va encore dire que tu
me chante avec vous dit une fois pour
toutes que que vous n'êtes jamais mais
je ne suis pas méchante qu'en fait ça
pour ça mais je le dis toujours capter
tout le monde le sait dans dix ans je
vous avais donné dire à quelqu'un en
quelques fois où il était méchant fois
que j'étais méchante mais avec vous
quelques cerises vous demandiez ce qui
se passe si je vous disais pas d oui
c'est vrai
alors là vous attachez vous pouvez ou
les noces du poumon droit
mais attention attention ce ne soit pas
toujours vous allez donner non mieux su
bien sûr ça c'est la lose pour la
première phase de la préparation mais
ensuite c'est à partir de maintenant qui
devient intéressant jusque là c'était
presque classique et on va les voir on
va faire une recette jury qui va
mélanger quelques pays les gens avec les
ans après alors que le steak barbare ah
oui voulez-vous avant la gentillesse de
me donnez lui le café alors ici grain
comme d'habitude de lui néanmoins comme
d'habitude et voulez vous alors l'indien
de revel à paris alors je vais avoir à
ces zones est un tout petit peu les
paupières comme ceux ci n'ont alors la
farine la voilà je m'en vais passer
chacune et pocket contre 6 dans la
farine puis les ranger c'est une à côté
des offres dans la terre sorte de mérite
à dire entendu de ce volet c'est une
relation facile
ça va mais à 3 août et n'oubliez pas
toujours mon cas
malgré ce que l'on peut penser initié
cette ascension alors ça va relativement
vite mais nous allons laisser colorer
simplement été que ça va être coloré
nous allons pouvoir mettre à genoux un
sourire puis un peu de soi que la fin
d'émission
les secours sont restés voilà que vous
redemande à la fois in the nestor est
pour le moment un jeu rude m'a alors
qu'une cour que l'état dedans rien avec
une ou deux secondes
merci donc à p & o ça va très vite alors
je vais simplement avec la caméra fait
de le voir retourner chacune des
roquettes
une seule fois parce que ça soit dorée à
trouvant là nous allons pouvoir laisser
cuire sur l'époque et sur elle même
voilà bien ça y est feu doux courir elle
en parle plus alors de suite je m'en
vais préparer une espèce de petit pâte à
frire mais tout à fait nous venons n'a
jamais fait jusqu'à présent de cette
façon là alors redonné mois la farine
dans l'enfer des beignets de 40
baignée de carotte qui accompagneront
alors voyons depuis y aurait deux petits
cuillérée de paris non non 2 puis 3 en 4
et 2 cuillerées un peu de sel un peu
d'huile
voilà un tout petit peu d'huile là une
épuration ensuite que qu'est ce que je
peux mettre dans l'isère
les sols gelés me jamais du pop non j'ai
cherché la requête est ici devant moi
voilà un un chantier une goutte de lait
comme ceci pour symbole pour ses
emprunts
et puis voilà c'est fini on mélange tout
ça regarde avec un peu de lait faisait
remarquer à peine voilà bien voilà la
pâte et où voyez vous l a été réalisé en
10 secondes
nous n'avons rien de plus à faire que
d'aller c'est comme ceci alors par in
depuis hier une cuillère à soupe d'huile
un peu de sel à 9 entier un petit peu de
lait c'est à dire à peu près la même
valeur en quantité que alors je veux des
carottes maintenant 4e en même temps la
même quantité de lait qu'ils que j'évite
d'offres oui le volume de 9 vous savez
que l'on peut quand même quand c'est
comme ça le regarde
alors maintenant il s'agit de déclarant
c'est comme ça oui un pendre les deux
coquilles d'oeuf et mesurée de quoi sa
moitié d'une coquille on a le
alors ici voyez-vous en coupe comme je
suis pour donner de la 6e à la carotte
proxy ci seront jolie par conséquent
tous les hommes aiment ça tu seras
gentil ça il est absolument que ce sera
tout pour aujourd'hui
alors voyez vous je les coupe dans un
sens et il a assez comme ça une julienne
ces poussières c'est ça il ya les outils
pour faire sonner c'est pas mentionné
vous pourrez même un outil qui s'appelle
des mandolines jamais été musicien et
aimer servir convenablement
et oui j'avais oublié et l'oublier c'est
vrai c'est vrai qu'après j'ai oublié mon
avis je n'ai pas vraiment je l'ait pas
fait qu'avec moi mais j'ai c'est vrai en
opération alors vous mettez tout genre
mais 2,4 une autoroute pour personnes
dépendantes et unique est fait derrière
oui ça me fera gagner un tout petit peu
de temps a tonné voulais pas je vais
mettre ça directement dans la pâte à
frire car il faut mettre ça que je les
fais je les mettre là dedans vous
étonnez vous allez voir je continue
parce que j'en ai pas tout à fait
j'en ai mis deux uniquement ça faisait 3
léo l'économie n'est ce pas ces voiliers
les hommes en écho la cote alors à la
répétition et coupez les carottes pour
faire voir wii wii fit je voulais tu
l'utilisés j'ai pas voulu qu'elle soit
perdue
ce que porte bien aujourd'hui
certains la c1 ce mois de juillet on
apprendra à contredire tout
la voilà ça y est allé à l'est mais tant
que ça soit terminé
le procédé de la carotte offert marché
là c'est le baudet bon eh bien pour vous
voyez je vais me mélanger ça comme ça si
ça vous appelez la pataterie tu as bien
sûr tu n'as pas tort non non ça fait
tout à fait ça effectivement mythique
tout à fait qu'avant vous me trouverez
pas bon je vais redonner un petit peu
cette idée
oui mais quand même un petit peu parce
que rio j'ai tout de même ajouter les
ratés sucre est là et puis tout de suite
tu m'avais les mettre à cuire
bon alors pour cela j'ai ici une
négresse avec vous aurez une négresse
sais que vous n'aimez pas ça et bien
partir de maintenant obligés soit sur ce
nom je vais les mettre bien profité pour
tourner les jeux les tournelles
c'est pour cela que je vous demande ça
humanise l'émission yves à ramallah
voulons pas les favoriser
inaria regarder si c'est joli je suis
très content de montrer quoi bon alors
expliquer ce que vous faites
alors regardez je prends comme ceux ci
une cuillerée pour ainsi dire je te
laisse tomber dans la future pas trop
vite
c'est sympa très très chaude par choix
parce que il faut quand même que les
services cuir ça va avoir les formes les
plus variées
les araignées c'est pour les gagner pas
et que les faucheurs non il faut les
manger cru je pense je fais maintenant
il paraît que ça avoue de noise rtc a
fait cette confidence
c'est un ami à moi qui avais de
sauternes ils mangent toujours les
faucheurs quand ils entrent dans les
faits les manuels et mentaux légers
résultat qui est délicieux il ne fait
rien du tout ou par le prochain c'est
une espèce de ben ali va t'en mets 10
images et les mâles et femelles
dans la matinée pourtant il manque
peut-être les deux bords vous araignées
sont terminées les araignées sont
terminées je vais récupère je sens que
ça va prêter à tressin voyez il ya là
une dernière la ne vais pas continuer de
croire qu'il est économe voilà eh bien
voilà quatrièmes n'ont plus qu'à laisser
le laisser cette fracture avec sa
représentée en tout cas un nom m'a sauté
en le sauternes est excellent 1 certes
mais là ce serait peut-être le
gaspillage non je crois que il faudrait
peut-être la voir un vin de sancerre
voyez-vous de ou de pouilly fumé là un
vin qu'ils soient passés n'ont pu manger
bien et fumées ont marqué que le pouilly
fuissé je pourrais en dire que pourrait
on dire presque autant que de sauter 1
c'est à dire que ce serait dommage de
mettre du quatrain grand devin parce que
c'est quand même non si si non mais
c'est pas une blague ronde des pains
plats grande alors voilà bien catherine
je crois que c'est terminé on pourrait
partir jeu qu'est ce que nous pourrions
faire baver couteau on va faire quelque
chose en attendant on va s'amuser
j'ai cependant que la friture continue
ici on va laver ses frais on a laissé
filer trop doucement et robin mélicie à
temps mais je crois qu'il faut dès qu'on
passe une petite chose quand même
alors vous savez je vous racontais
l'histoire d'un coup puisque vous avez
garé à côté c'est ça alors ici il s'agit
d'une recette absolument française
typiquement française les alouettes en
tête les beignets les carottes
c'est typiquement japonais ah ça c'est
absolument exact
et bien nous allons faire une sauce
typiquement chinoise voilà comme ça nous
aurons touché à tout alors voyez vous
une figurait dessus et 2 cuillerées de
sucre ceci crée mais vous savez
catherine que leucan ameliste français
l'économie française est un des premiers
livres de cuisine qui était écrit car
autrefois l'as cannes amiens la canam m
ou quand la mienne et duras canne à
sucre et donc toutes les sauces il y
avait du sucre ont tout absolument tout
c'est pas pour ça qu'il faut continuer
ah oui mais pourquoi ne compte que
n'aurions pas le chinois les chinois ont
toujours eu lieu c'est pas pareil
alors voyez vous regarde alors là j'ai
mis depuis reims uc rien n'a pas tout à
fait assez juin ajouté transport 2
cuillerées de sucre
je mets une troisième cuillerée de sucre
alors regardez je fais un caramel léger
et blanc alors voulez-vous de données
volées on allait à côté de vous le jus
de citron
voilà le jus de citron voilà et on va
réduire tout simplement le sucre qui a
été caramélisées avec le jus de citron
ça va faire une sauce aigre-douce
chinoise mais ça nous l'utilisons tout à
l'heure ça c'était au milieu
tous le monde en nous allons maintenant
extraire les dents avant de retourner
je crois que j'ai un petit panier où
j'avais un petit panier gens vous m'en
servir
là les beignets non non je les retourne
et je vais les laisser cuire 2 secondes
de plus alors je tiens à préciser
quelque chose
les japonais ne font pas rire tout
appris qu ils vont simplement doré alors
elle reste pro quand elle reste 2008 et
ce n'est pas une forte n'est ce pas je
tiens à le préciser
il s'agit de les cuire seulement
quelques minutes comme je viens de le
faire il s'agit pas du tout de les
laisser une demi heure dans la friture
pas du tout alors voyez vous ici l'on
les égoutter comme ceux ci en les
écoutant rappeler en quoi consiste la
fat afrique qui est vraiment alors la
pâte à frire consistante 2 cuillères à
soupe de farine une cuillère à soupe
c'est depuis halle un peu de sel la même
valeur un oeuf entier la même valeur que
leurs chantiers
là on va laisser comme ceux ci la même
valeur que l'oeuf entier de de l'est et
puis on mélange tout ensemble avec un
peu de sel bon alors ici je m'en vais
déjà commencer à sortir les jeux alors
je vous ai demandé un peu d'eau je crois
qu'elle doit être à côté de moi vous
voulez la mettre là aller au sort les
paupiettes en laisse réduire fortement
la fête réussie vous concevez kg 2
là
je vais déglacer soit avec du vin blanc
soit avec de l'eau allons aujourd'hui je
n'ai pas de les oublier
[Musique]
maintenant oui mais ce n'est pas une
nécessité absolue
alors voyez vous une goutte d'eau une
vous deviendra sec justement du vin
blanc de couy sur loire où deux ou deux
le sancerre ne paraît être tout à fait
bien en l'occurrence là alors je laisse
rien vous des glaces et bien comme il
faut
car il s'agit des glaçages et puis de
les ajouter le jus de citron avec le
caramel n'est pas le reste
viens chercher fini vous les voies
volonté de me donner la fécule alors
voici la fécule je mets une pincée de
fécule comme ceux ci une cuillerée jo
voilà je dissous jamais d'un seul enjeu
mais dans la sauce et hausse pardon je
mets ici
chacune de ces croquettes autour du plat
n'est pas là non ça va c'est très chaud
mais pas assez pour me brûler voilà ce
sont les 1 800 têtes télévision de
seconde que je m associe la soul dessus
et voilà quatre ans nous avons terminé
monsieur au travail
merci de m'en voilà bon appétit à tous
[Musique]